we have three loosely related tools so
first up this little beckons and not
included your title about my over here I
have put my models in the clusters
thanks thanks thanks a lot and thanks to
organizers for a really good semester
and a really good workshop it's been a
lot of fun so I'm gonna talk about some
algorithms that you can derive from some
classical statistical physics tools but
I wanted to start before getting into my
talk just by showing a couple of
simulations and so the the running
example I'll be using today is just the
ferromagnetic Potts model so I wrote the
partition function here sum over all QQ
colorings of a graph e to the minus beta
times the number of by chromatic edges
induced by this coloring so that just a
classical ferromagnetic Potts model the
simulation you'll see is three color
pops model on some sort of 2d tourists
okay
I started all pink and as we run these
so this is glob or dynamics sort of
patched together making little updates
and quite quickly you see that somehow
the picture looks quite disordered okay
so that maybe that's not so surprising
beta is small here let me change the
parameter of beta to something larger
and the picture looks a lot different
so we have this sea of pink and we have
these small little islands of blue and
white that sort of a born and die grow a
little bit but there's clearly something
very different going on here I think
everyone knows here knows that this is
this is some finite evidence of a phase
transition and so this the global
dynamics is having a very hard time
getting away from this all pink
configuration and getting you know
there's symmetry in the model ideally
you would also be seeing blue dominant
phase a white dominant phase and so I
mean you know this is this is a theorem
that on say ZD for large enough beta
there is a phase transition there slow
mixing and things like this now
and so the Markov chain glabra dynamics
is not a good sampling algorithm for
this particular graph and these
particular parameters and now if
probably if you've ever heard someone
say that your first reaction and my
first reaction is come on you know just
just symmetrize between the states
it doesn't actually seem like a barrier
and and somehow this picture actually
looks simpler than the other picture you
know this is like a lot of pink and then
some small defects okay and then so my
whole talk today is how do you make such
an idea rigorous how how can you
actually say that it's enough to
symmetrize between the states maybe not
using Markov chain but use some other
algorithm and really make rigorous the
idea that this looks simpler and the
other picture okay and so that's that's
what we'll do that's all for the
simulation okay so let's start and let
me tell you what I'll I'll be talking
about so sort of the talk will go in
Reverse historical order so I'll tell
you a result about expander' graphs from
a paper of mine with Matthew Jensen and
Peter kibosh
but somehow the key algorithmic idea
comes from a paper an earlier paper with
Tyler Hellmuth who's here and who's Rex
and and this paper was really inspired
you know the method of barber knock and
Patel Rex but the actual algorithm isn't
there algorithm the algorithm actually
comes from some classical statistical
physics so the Meyer expansion or the
cluster expansion
Pirogov seen I theories you'll hear more
about later today it's a radnyx version
of this there's lots and lots of work in
statistical physics on this cluster
expansion will will use a particular
theorem of Kotetsu key and price but the
point today is that actually in all of
this work there was algorithm lurking
and not not so far below the surface and
I'll show you that algorithm today okay
good so I'll just give a few definitions
so we have the Potts model we have and
our goal is going to be to approximate
the partition function or the sample
what's an epsilon approximation its
value Z hat and I'll just I like this
parameterization better so that this is
at most e to the epsilon Z and at least
e to the minus epsilon Z okay so that's
our goal and FP tasks we've seen this we
want to compute and epsilon
approximation time polynomial and and
one over epsilon and the class of graphs
I'll talk about today is expander graphs
and here's one notion of expander graphs
an alpha expander is a graph where the
the number of edges so partial EES is
just the number of edges exiting a
vertex set s is it at least alpha times
the size of s for all s this that is not
too big so let's say at most n over 2 so
and will always be the number of
vertices of the graph ok so that's this
is the class of graphs we'll talk about
and then what's the theorem that I'll
tell you
[Music]
the theorem and this is in this paper
with Matthew Jensen and Peter kibosh say
for all you at least to Delta at least
three beta at least or log Q Delta over
alpha there's an FP toss and an
efficient sampling algorithm for the
plots model on Alpha expanders max
degree Delta that's the theorem and
notice that this is like a
low-temperature result usually the
algorithms we hear it's high temperature
if beta is small enough if lambda is
small enough in the hard core model
here's the other other extreme if beta
is large enough if we're you know far
enough into this phase coexistence
regime then there's an efficient
government okay
so I want to start by just doing a like
a schematic picture so remember we had
the simulation we had this big pink C
and these little islands of other colors
so let's let's draw that so today we're
mostly red and then what what else do we
see we're gonna see some other small
components so maybe like a few green
vertices maybe a few green vertices and
a few blue vertices next to them maybe
some blue component another blue and
green component
and so let's say we have a configuration
like this in our expander graph I'm
gonna call these connected components of
non red vertices I'll call them polymers
and and I warn you already this is
somehow bad bad terminology because
there's something else in statistical
physics called the polymer but this is
this is historical or okay and so what
properties do these parameters have
these polymers have also gamma I is a
connected subgraph of non red vertices
plus one property if you look at the
distance between gamma I and gamma J for
I not equal to J this is at least two in
the graph otherwise they would form one
connected component and then I'm going
to define a function I would call it
like the surface energy or something so
the surface energy of gamma I will just
be the number of by chromatic edges
incident to gamma I and so what do I
mean there so remember these are these
are connected set of vertices certainly
all the edges that leave this polymer
are by chromatic because they go to red
vertices but you might also inside have
some by chromatic so this counts all of
these okay that's nice and so right away
we can write this that for this
particular configuration coloring Sigma
e to the minus beta times the number of
by chromatic edges equals the product
over these polymers e to the minus beta
time's this surface energy so this is
this is the weight of the pots
configuration in the pots model and I've
just written it as a product over these
polymers that's nice and now what I can
do is I'm going to define a function
that's kind of like a partition function
z red let me say let me add one thing
these are connected subgraph with non
red vertices and these are also small so
let's say they have at most n over two
vertices and in particular since they're
small we know that the surface energy is
at least alpha times the size because
it's an expanding graph so at least you
these are all small vertex sets and we
have this expansion property this
definition of expansion the number of
edges going out is at least alpha times
the size and so we have some lower bound
on this surface energy term okay and now
I'm going to define Z red to be the sum
over all collections of compatible
polymers what compatible is product over
gamma and X so compatible polymers I
just mean that it's a collection of
polymers whose distances at least two
that's Z red
[Music]
and then we have a lemma least for log
Delta over alpha Q times Z red and e to
the minus n approximation the real parts
so here I've defined some partition
function that's supposed to represent
the configurations where you see mostly
red in the C and there's some symmetry
among the color so if you multiply by Q
you get some contribution from
configurations where there's some
dominant color and what we're saying
here is that actually this this is a
very very good approximation of the real
partition function ok so what is this
really this is really like a slow mixing
result right you've shown that there's
some exponentially small cut in your
state space and I guess it's a bit
surprising but somehow this slow mixing
result is going to be a necessary
ingredient to find this efficient
algorithm but but it's but we need more
than this so you know when you're when
you're proving slow mixing you just need
to show that there's an exponentially
small cut you don't need to say that
like that's the only cut and within the
pieces everything is next what we'll
show next is that within these pieces
like the configurations corresponding to
Z red things are nice multiplicative
approximation it's really a good
practice approximation because I mean
into the end
this conference and many other new to
the - end well that's the same thing is
right this is really about experiments
and it's not same thing about lattices
it's know you'll see later today so to
do lattices it's going to be much much
harder ok this this is the easy that is
it thing ok good so yeah so any
questions at the flow at this point
we're gonna we're going to take a detour
now away from the Potts model into some
abstract setting and this is the idea of
abstract polymer models the terminology
is due to a Gruber I think 72 the brew
ssin in the 90s tried to get people
adopt a different terminology because
polymers need something else of animal
models and the the terminology is
actually quite vivid but it didn't catch
on unfortunately okay so abstract
polymer models we have some graph G we
have some set let's see curly C of
polymers gamma and gamma is a connected
polymers are connected subgraph with a
spin assignment maybe and a weight
function each polymer comes with a
weight function W sub gamma this could
be real complex anything you like and
there's a notion of compatibility so we
say gamma is compatible with gamma prime
if in the graph in which they live
distances at least two okay so this
should be familiar and then we can
define a partition function so Z will be
the sum over all collections of
compatible polymers so mutually
compatible polymers product over these
polymers weight of gamma some abstract
version of a partition function notice
that this partition function here I
described fits exactly into this model
an even simpler example is you have some
graph G and your polymers are just
single single vertices okay and the
weight function of each vertex is just
lambda so what does it mean to sum over
a collection of vertices that are
pairwise compatible distance at least to
this is something over independent sets
so this is just the hard core model if
you're these are your polymers and so in
some sense the abstract polymers are a
way to map some general spend system
into a hard core model which is quite a
nice thing I think you turn the N you
put all the interaction into the weight
function and then all you have is the
Hardcore compatibility relation okay
good
right and so now what I wanted to tell
you is what is the cluster expansion so
we have to we have a few more
definitions so let's say we have a tuple
capital gamma of polymers so this is an
ordered multi set of polymer so you
might have like five copies of the same
polymer in their tuple H of gamma is its
incompatibility graph so it's it's a
graph with vertices representing each
polymer and the tuple and an edge if
you're incompatible so if your tuple for
example is gamma 1 gamma 1 gamma 1 the
incompatibility graph is a triangle
because you're always incompatible with
yourself okay I'll say the size of a
tuple is the sum over all the polymers
in the tuple the size of the polymer a
number of vertices in the sub graph I
also need a combinatorial function so
the Earth's cell function graph H is 1
over the number of vertices factorial
sum over all subsets of the edges and
these subsets have to be connected what
I mean by connected is if you take the
vertex set of H and the set of edges a
this graph is connected ok so you have
to yeah it also have to be spanning and
minus 1/2 the size of this is some
combinatorial function of a graph the
earth cell function it turns out it's
some evaluation of the top polynomial
where it's like the the linear
coefficient of the chromatic polynomial
I think it also has some other
combinatorial names ok and so what is
the cluster expansion
so the cluster expansion is going to be
an infinite series representation of log
Z and it's at the moment it's formal
just a formal power series and what it
actually is it's it's going to be the
multivariate Taylor series for log Z in
the variables of the weight functions
around zero so you can you can derive it
this way this somehow wasn't observed in
until many years later by de Bruin but
what is it it's gonna be the sum over
all oh I should say one thing luster so
what is a cluster gamma is a cluster if
each of gamma is connected so just sum
over all these tuples whose
incompatibility graph is connected you
have this combinatorial factor and then
you just multiply the weights that's a
cluster expansion notice that it's it
really is an infinite series because a
cluster could consist of K copies of the
same polymer for any K so it really is
infinite I mean I mean no no I mean but
like yeah I mean the fact that these are
connected gives like for your Taylor
series thing a polynomial time algorithm
so yeah so it's useful
okay so right so this is just a formal
power series and then you can ask when
does it converge okay and how fast does
it converge and so here here we'll use a
useful theorem and so so this is this is
a very very widely studied topic in
statistical physics when does this
series converge and I'm just going to
give one like convenient theorem it's
not not the first or necessarily
sharpest but it's convenient so this is
Kotetsu key and price and the condition
is if for all polymers gamma if you sum
over the polymers incompatible with
gamma o the absolute value of the weight
let's say e to the size this should be
less than the size of gamma okay so this
is the condition and then the conclusion
is that cluster expansion converges
absolutely and in particular the
partition function is not zero okay so
so like one okay one thing one thing you
see immediately is what do you need you
need some sort of exponential decay of
the weight functions in the size okay
you need to kill off this exponential
but you also need to kill off this sum
over all possible polymers I guess I
should remark that what what did we
really do here in this case we we we
switched from from low temperature to
high temperature when beta is large so
low temperature here these weight
functions get smaller and smaller okay
so that's that's the whole idea of what
we're doing is with this abstract
polymer model we're switching from low
temperature to high temperature and this
is saying if you're your weights these
weights in this following run model are
small enough so if beta is large enough
then the series converges okay so that's
that's good right so you have one
polymer sitting in your graph so this is
gamma and you need to sum over all the
polymers that somehow touch it so it
includes it includes itself includes any
polymer that shares a vertex includes
any polymer that's within distance one
jacent in the incompatibility graph yeah
exactly
okay so this is a nice theorem this is
used this theorem is used for example by
Allen Sokol and proving something about
the roots of the chromatic polynomial so
it's it's this is really a tool you can
think of it like a tool in combinatorics
to prove zero free regions of
polynomials and it's quite useful for if
we want to study algorithms we want to
get a bit more control on the rate of
convergence and so this is a not too
hard corollary of this theorem which is
suppose for all vertices in my graph my
underlying graph if I sum over all the
polymers that contain this particular
vertex and I look at the absolute value
of the wave function I said you need to
twice the size of the polymer this is at
most one over if this graph has max
degree Delta one over Delta plus one so
a bit stronger condition and then what
do we get we get some good exponential
decay of exponential convergence of this
series so I'll say TN I'll define this
in one second
TN minus log Z is at most n times e to
the minus M and what is TM
so TM will just be the sum over all
clusters whose size is at most M and
remember this is the sum of the sizes of
the polymers inside it and then this is
just the truncated cluster expansion and
so if you have this stronger condition
what this is saying is this
approximation gets better quickly and
this implies that if M is let's say log
n over epsilon then X of TN is an
epsilon approximation disease
okay that's good so this suggests an
algorithm enumerate all clusters of size
at most log n over epsilon there are
cell functions the weight functions
multiply them up and add them up and
output okay so that's the algorithm it's
just truncate this cluster expansion I'm
why can we do this efficiently so here
we really why can we enumerate clusters
so clusters are connected objects and G
has bounded degree this is essentially
enumerated objects and some sort of
bounded degree graph it's a little bit
subtle because you can have multiple
polymers but this is why you can do this
efficiently why can you compute the or
cell function efficiently it turns out
you can compute the coefficients of the
Tut polynomial in vertex exponential
time
there's no the super old Brazil's right
this is from 2008 yeah so it's by and
it's a bit surprising I guess by
Bjorklund haasvelt Caskey and Koivisto
from 2008
so vortex exponential time is enough
because we just have clusters of size
log n in the examples I've shown
computing the wave functions is pretty
trivial but in other applications this
might not be trivial and then
multiplying in sum and output okay so
any questions about the algorithm and so
somehow somehow you know the hidden
inside the derivation of the cluster
expansion are these kind of Newton
identities that Patel Rex use to show
that you can compute these coefficients
efficiently but that's somehow hidden in
this derivation of the cluster expansion
so now we just need to prove the theorem
and so what we need to do is we need to
check for this Potts model these Potts
model polymers that this condition here
holds and so what do we need to do we
need to look at the sum over all
polymers containing a certain vertex the
weight function is e to the minus beta
times the surface energy twice the size
okay so this is this is the thing we
want to bound this is at most the sum so
now we use expansion this is at most e
to the minus beta alpha times the size
of polymer okay and now now we can sum
over all possible sizes of the polymers
how many possible connected graphs
labeled by Q minus 1 colors are there
something like e Delta Q minus 1 okay
and we have e to the minus beta alpha
minus 2 okay so this is some exponential
sum in K and we just need beta to be
large enough so this is less than you do
the algebra 1 over Delta plus 1 if beta
is at least okay so that that's that's
the algorithm and/or the proof and so
what else can I tell you about this so
let me tell you a couple things so this
gives you an FPS for this problem
well what about sampling
sampling is a little bit subtle so
normally we think sampling and counting
efficient counting are equivalent and
what would you do you would do some sort
of self reduce ability and so one thing
you would you could try is spin by spin
in this plots model set the spin to
something and then go on so what one
problem that you might consider in this
case is what if you ruin your expansion
right we had some expansion properties
and once you start to set boundary
conditions you can ruin this so the
sampling algorithm actually works it's
self reducibility
but on the level of polymers okay so the
idea is to pick a vertex V and choose
which if any polymer gamma that contains
V is in the configuration X and you do
this by computing partition functions or
approximating partition functions so you
have your you have your big graph you
pick some vertex and then what you want
to decide is is there no polymer that
contains this is that this polymer is it
this polymer and you have to go through
all these polymers and check you know
compute different partition functions
and see with what probability is a
particular polymer there and then you
either add it or add nothing to your
this set that you're going to grow and
then what happens you've added a polymer
you know no other polymer that contains
V can be in the set and you also know
that this nothing that is within
distance one can be in the set so you've
taken your set of polymers
and you remove a bunch of polymers that
are now forbidden from being in the
configuration and so you you're left
with some set of polymers C prime that's
a subset of your original set of
polymers and one one nice thing is that
in the setting of these abstract
polymers in this Kotetsu key price
condition and if you have this condition
holding for a set of polymer c then it
holds for any subset because the the
condition it's only easier to satisfy if
you have less polymers okay so you can
you can do the entire algorithm with any
subset of polymers whether or not this
subset of polymers corresponds to a spin
model or not okay so it's it's a little
bit surprising but some arbitrary subset
of polymers won't necessarily can
correspond to some spin system with
boundary conditions but you know the
algorithm goes through completely fine
this graph of polymers exactly good so
yeah so what does this imply in
particular so this implies in particular
that if you throw away all polymers that
are of size bigger than log n over
epsilon beckon you can only lose epsilon
in your partition function right because
basically the contribution to the
partition function of these the the
subsets of polymers of sizes at most log
in a rep salon is a 1 minus epsilon
approximation it's fine because it's
absolute convergence so I I didn't state
it as as strong as it really is the it
really says that if you sum over all the
terms of the cluster expansion with each
term absolute value
so you just strangle it okay yeah
right so you can you could this
immediately tells you you don't have any
big polymers that matter so I think the
interesting situations and then somehow
high order terms like cancel each other
or something like that and that happens
from time to time right so that you can
throw them all together or none of them
right I mean this won't capture this
okay yeah so yeah maybe I'll make some
related remarks in the last five minutes
so good so we talked about sampling yeah
so let me make a couple remarks one is
that I guess in statistical physics
language the cluster expansion is a
perturbative method and you shouldn't
ever expect it to be tight and so you
know we're always you know unlike
something like Liang theorem or
something like that when you're looking
for exact regions here it's always going
to be something like for something large
enough and that's that's just something
inherent in a method like this another
thing is that I said that the cluster
expansion is the multivariate Taylor
series in the weights and so if your
weight functions like our weight
functions in this putz model our
analytic functions in some other
parameter so our functions were
polynomials in each of the minus beta
then actually the the cluster expansion
and the Taylor series are the same thing
just organized differently but but the
caveat is that it's not always the case
that the wave functions are analytic
functions of some other parameter okay
and Tyler will talk something about this
but the wave functions can get pretty
nasty and maybe the wave functions
themselves are not analytic and so there
is there is a subtle difference between
the Taylor series approach and this
approach and then
and another another remark is that if
you have some condition like this then
somehow probabilistically you understand
the model really really well so you can
derive things like so certainly somehow
the model is analytic you can derive
things like exponential decay of
correlations so immediately from this
you get something like that the the
correlation between the presence of two
polymers decays exponentially in the dip
in their distance you can derive central
limit theorems on like the number of
patterns of certain types you can derive
lots and lots of things like this and
this there's a survey by de Bruin I
guess
lectures like 1995 where he where he has
this like animal model terminology but
he also talks about is basically trying
to encourage propolis to use the cluster
expansion because you can derive lots of
probabilistic information so what we're
saying here is actually there's also a
lot of algorithmic content when you when
you have this strong condition and then
right and I guess going going back to
the original simulation what you really
would like is just that like some local
Markov chain can sample in this region
and this this is quite a difficult and
not so fast algorithm but really what
you would like is to be able to prove
something about some local markups and
clearly not globe or dynamics but some
local Markov chain to say that really
that intuition that we all have when we
first hear a slow mixing that just
symmetrized between the states that's
true we still haven't shown that but at
least we've shown that you can do
something how grooming okay so I'll stop
there
[Applause]
[Music]
so yeah so as I've stated it the
dependence is like and over epsilon to
the log Delta if you have stronger if
you satisfy this in a stronger way then
you can reduce the running time there
you can do it like in so the hypercube
okay yeah so the I'm doing something
about the hypercube now but there you
can basically got a good approximation
in almost no time so sub linear so if
you have if you have lots of expansion
the running time goes down a lot
but you still need to compute the top
polynomial of these but the question is
how many how many terms do you need to
get a good approximate it turns out in
like the hypercube case you just need a
constant number
you don't need log n because there's a
much there's a much more general theorem
stated in the Kotetsu key price paper
where you you're allowed arbitrary
functions up here and then the the
running the decay depends on these
functions and there you can take a
function that actually is much bigger as
the size of the polymer right so it
doesn't have this much expansion but it
has enough expansion so so David Galvin
and Prasad have a paper about graphs
like the hypercube slow mixing if you
can do slow mixing with like tweaking
parameters a little bit you can get an
algorithm I guess that's a bit strange
but it's a bit controversial again
[Music]
okay this is a 15-minute break reconvene
at 10:30 things again
[Applause]